the manga for hell's paradise finally
finished this week on chapter 127
after over two years of serialization
but for any fans who were saddened by
this news we were picked up by the fact
that an anime adaptation has been
announced for it
which is insanely exciting hell's
paradise is the last of the dark trio
in shonen jump alongside jiu jitsu
kaisen and chainsaw man
to have an anime adaptation announced
and for me this is just as exciting if
not more
than these other two today i'm going to
briefly get into what hell's paradise is
even about
since it is certainly the least well
known and most underrated of these three
what's amazing about it and of course
why you should be hype
spoiler free as always
hell's paradise follows gabi maru the
hollow the most renowned shinobi of the
iwagakude village
which is basically an easier way to say
that he is japan's most
lethal bloodthirsty assassin one that is
feared and known by everyone but has
been captured by the shogunate after
being betrayed by the rest of his
village
and here it's actually revealed that
gabimaru has long moved past the
reputation that many hold to his name
he's tired of killing and fighting and
as the shogunate try and execute him
over and over he manages to escape each
time despite
being bound up and seemingly willing to
accept execution
but we realized after a chapter so that
he doesn't truly want to die here
he wants to return to his wife she's the
reason he's softened up from all this
time and is tired of killing
and so this is gabimaru's one goal from
the start
to return to her and thus the shogunate
offers him a chance to do that
the shogun is dispatching a number of
the strongest and most dangerous
criminals on death row to an island
south of japan in search of the elixir
of life
the key to immortality the one who finds
it will be pardoned and may continue
with the rest of their life free from
their crimes
which is perfect for gabimaru i guess
and because this island shrouded in
mystery is known as an island of
paradise
and of course the shogunate don't trust
a bunch of criminals
the shogun is sending each convict with
a renowned executioner as their partner
in case the criminal acts out in any way
tries to escape pull a fast one
one of the famous beheaders of the
yasaimon clan can kill them without
hesitating
but as we get to this paradise we
quickly realized that things are not the
way they were made out to be
and that this island may be far more
dangerous than they initially thought
and that is my dramatic reenactment of
the synopsis
i mean at surface level it's a really
complex and cool
battle royale a bunch of people sent to
an island to search for the single
elixir of life that only one of them can
get
but you get a couple chapters deep and
it's actually got this incredibly
dynamic relationship between the two
sides who've been sent to the island
the executioners and the criminals on
one hand of course the executioners have
an obligation to kill the criminals
should they do
anything out of the ordinary but on the
other as things get more dangerous
very very quickly you realize that the
executioners can't afford to be
beheading the criminals
who might be the only people who can
help them escape
and through this we see these very
strange and unique bonds being forged
between enemies
who can either grow to love each other
or just be fighting together out of the
obligation to survive
not every executioner cares about
beheading criminals
some only do it because it's their job
some believe that the criminal doesn't
deserve the punishment they've been
given
and of course there's the hard asses who
really don't trust criminals of any sort
but have to keep going on this kind of
enemy of my enemy is my friend type of
story
and because of this story dynamic what
we get is a group of characters who are
all
super different from each other none of
them came to this island with the same
goal in mind with the same backstory
but they all try and leave with the same
purpose survival
and that is one of the key themes of
hell paradise it's the questioning of
the meaning of life
that at the end of the day preserving
yourself in your life should probably
come before all else
that after all if you're dead you can't
really do anything
or that perhaps once you meet people
like you who are strong-willed good
people
maybe they are something worth dying for
when you're presented with an unbeatable
unbreaking threat in front of you what
is the first thing you do
what will you choose to act on in what
may be your last moments
that's the beauty of hell's paradise and
that is what it seeks to explore
and so the story itself though i called
it a battle royale of sorts earlier
is much more complicated than that it
becomes this very convoluted and
interesting mystery that continues to
get unraveled throughout
and because we have all these different
characters we have different pieces of
the puzzle being solved by various pairs
and groups of executioners and criminals
who cross paths at different points it's
a super cool
and unique way of storytelling the likes
of which we see in shows like bakano and
the fate series if you've watched any of
those
it doesn't really jump through time or
anything complex like that but
it does have a bunch of moving parts
that definitely keep the plot constantly
moving and interesting
the main character gabi maru and his
executioner escort also have this really
great partnership between them
as they both try and understand their
purpose for existing really
gabimaru is hard set in his goal and has
really no hesitation
after all a life of being the world's
greatest shinobi should probably lead to
that
and the assimon beheader on the other
hand is basically the opposite
as a woman in a field dominated by men
she is already discriminated against as
a beheader
and finds little meaning or purpose in
what she's doing besides to prove a
point
and so these characters get closer and
we set them open up not just to each
other but to themselves
and the same can be said of all the
characters in this story frankly
since it isn't really a huge cast they
all come to realizations about
themselves and their purpose for being
here and what they want to do with their
life
and this is what makes the story and
characters great
the manga is totally addicting i started
and caught up in about two days and it
was a crazy ride
i actually caught up two weeks ago so
two chapters before the end
and for anyone who wants to read it all
as well you can do it all in one go and
so i do highly recommend it
between jiujitsu kaisen and chainsaw man
i'd probably put hell's paradise right
in the middle
when looking at both how dark the manga
is and how well it fits the broader
umbrella term shonen
hell's paradise is very much a manga
that is ready to kill off its characters
it keeps you on edge throughout and you
always have to be prepared to see
one of the characters maybe even your
favorite to die
as i mentioned before this is a big part
of the central theme it aims to prove
but in terms of the pretty
straightforward plot character motives
enemies
battles power ups it's very much still a
shonen manga
and that is certainly exciting not
because shonen manga and anime are the
best of course
but because they do appeal to the
biggest audience
and thus my hopes as a reader and big
fan of this manga already that it'll
become a successful adaptation and
gather even more fans are certainly high
as i said my chainsaw main video having
the shonen jump stamp on it should give
hell's paradise a nice boost
in anticipation whenever the anime
finally comes out
not that it really needs a head start
really it's a great manga on its own
and so this shift in what is being
turned into an anime from
shonen is really exciting to me the fact
that we got jujutsu kaisen recently
which is still airing of course chainsaw
man was announced and now this
it's bringing a level of maturity to
mainstream anime that i'm really excited
to see
maybe because as i'm getting older these
are very interesting to me
or maybe just because it's fresh it's
something new to bring to the shonen
genre which is
of course aimed towards younger
audiences
and of course when i'm saying this i
don't think that the show is super dark
or super intense
too much so for younger audiences not at
all but i do think it's maturing and
that's something that i look forward to
if you're a manga reader i highly
recommend it it's a great read
and super interesting for any anime
watchers it's certainly something to
look forward to and to anticipate
it should definitely be on your radar
and your plant to watch list for the
next year or two
whenever its final airing date gets
announced
which i am hoping is soon
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses